today on the matt wall show the biden
administration celebrates pride month
with executive orders meant to ensure
that more children are drugged and
castrated also protesters interrupt a
drag queen story hour and are now being
investigated for a hate crime because of
it but a hate crime against who and
texas lawmakers send a letter to the
white house asking for an official legal
definition of the word woman good
question based on my experience they're
not going to get one though ibram kendy
has a new book out meant to indoctrinate
more children into the crt cult in our
daily cancellation george washington
university changes its colonials moniker
for
reasons that make no sense whatsoever
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
well that summer vacation you have
planned is expensive on its own but now
let's add in the higher cost of gas
credit card fees which are already close
to 19 and are expected to rise again
soon it's becoming impossible to save
any money to enjoy some time away after
all your hard work this year don't let
all those expenses ruin all your plans
though instead save some money and get a
free mortgage review from our friends at
american financing let a salary-based
mortgage mortgage consultant talk to you
about custom loans that can fit your
budget better
and that's the truth i mean from your
home loan to your equity and even your
high interest debt they'll review all of
it and it's very easy for you on your
end anyway and they'll do everything
they can to help you save up to a
thousand dollars a month these are huge
savings and you can help avoid um all
the the the costs and everything and the
heartache that comes with going on that
dream summer vacation if you're ready to
save up to a thousand dollars a month
pick up the phone and give them a call
if you start soon you could skip two
payments and may close in as fast as 10
days all you gotta do is call 866
569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
one of the iron-clad rules of modern
life and something that i wish
conservatives would finally come to
understand once and for all and never
forget
is that the left always doubles down
always escalates we call it
progressivism because it always
progresses progresses in the way that
you know cancer progresses this means
that if we are moderate in our
opposition if we settle for half
measures or worse if we backtrack if we
triangulate we're going to become
overwhelmed and eventually drowned out
of the conversation entirely
the other thing to keep in mind is that
the left owns all of our cultural
institutions which means that they own
the culture which means that as they
push ever to the left they drag the
entire culture along with them so this
explains the sad pathetic story of
moderate conservatism so-called you know
the moderate conservative is looking to
you know stake out the uh the halfway
position between the right and the left
but the halfway point is itself caught
up in this riptide and drifting quickly
to the left that's how we end up with
conservatives who today
support at least some of the underlying
presuppositions of critical race theory
and gender theory
they've adopted a belief system that
would have been too radically
progressive even for leftists 10 years
ago
which is why it's inevitable that 10
years from now these same moderate
conservatives will be proclaiming their
support for uh sex change surgeries for
kindergartners but insisting that only
adults should be able to medically
transition to a new species
that's that's where they draw the line
now this new this species stuff that's
only for for 18 year old and over with
some exceptions
this will be the moderate and reasonable
viewpoint in 2032 if not much sooner
than that
so case in point the world professional
association for transgender health this
is one of the most prominent and
influential health organizations in the
world
they come up with standards of care that
are automatically endorsed by you know
the american academy of pediatrics the
american psychological association and
so on they also as we discussed a couple
of weeks ago you may remember uh w path
from a couple weeks ago they came out in
support of eunuch
as a valid gender identity so that's
where they're coming from
and after receiving lots of criticism
for that and for all of the other lunacy
that they push and they advocate wpath
has responded by doing what these people
always do their message to the public
basically is oh you don't like it when
we push gender transitions on children
well guess what now we're going to push
transitions on even younger children how
do you like that
as yahoo reports quote the world
professional association for transgender
health said hormones could be started at
age 14 two years earlier than the
group's previous advice and some
surgeries done at age 15 or 17 a year or
so earlier than previous guidance the
group acknowledged potential risks but
said that it's unethical and harmful to
withhold early treatment
of course doctors already have been
chemically castrating 14 year old
children chopping the breasts off of 15
year old girls and all the rest of it
but now the practice has the official
endorsement of a group whose
declarations are taken as unquestioned
gospel truth by every other medical
organization in the entire western world
how do they justify this well
you know i mean what do they say to the
objections raised by transphobes who are
so hateful as to insist that maybe
children shouldn't have their healthy
body parts removed
they do have a rebuttal of sorts and i
want you to listen to this listen to the
the language that's being used here okay
it's not very subtle quote starting
treatment earlier allows transgender
teens to experience physical puberty
changes around the same time as other
teens said dr eli coleman chair of the
group's standards of care and director
of the university of minnesota medical
school's human sexuality program
but he stressed that age is just one
factor to be weighed emotional maturity
parents consent long-standing gender
discomfort and a careful psychological
evaluation are among the others quote
certainly there are adolescents that do
not have the emotional or cognitive
maturity to make an informed decision he
said
that's why we recommend a careful
multi-discipline disciplinary assessment
uh you see only some adolescents lack
the cognitive maturity to consent
but there's nothing about adolescence
itself which should just disqualify
children from making these kinds of
decisions he says
it's not a coincidence or a mere
byproduct that they are now chipping
away at the legal framework that
protects children from sexual abuse
that framework is built entirely around
the idea that children
no child can actually offer informed
consent
that's the whole point that's the
framework no child can offer informed
consent it's impossible
that's why we say it's impossible for a
child and an adult to have a sexual
relationship
because that's not a relationship that's
rape every time
why because the child cannot consent he
doesn't have the cognitive maturity yet
wpath now declares that only some
children lack cognitive to maturity
other children are so much sure that
they can consent to having body parts
removed they can consent to
sterilization
they can consent to castration
the whole concept of consent is being
intentionally confused and corrupted
they know what they're doing
and so do we and we know why they're
doing it
but wpath wasn't the only group to
double down on lgbt extremism this week
yesterday the white house celebrated
pride month
with two executive orders one is meant
to quote protect lgbt people from quote
discriminatory laws that have been
passed in a number of states
namely the laws which banned doctors
from castrating kids ban males from
female sports and banned teachers from
sexually indoctrinating preschoolers
biden now seeks to protect these
children
by making sure that they are
indoctrinated and castrated for the
other executive order here's the white
house statement explaining it it says
as a candidate president biden pledged
to help end so-called conversion therapy
a discredited and dangerous practice
that seeks to suppress or change the
sexual orientation or gender identity of
lgbtqi plus people
today president biden is using his
executive authority to launch an
initiative to protect children across
america and crack down on this harmful
practice which every major medical
association in the united states has
condemned
keep in mind of course that conversion
therapy also includes telling a boy
that he's a boy that's conversion
therapy
right according to the left if a parent
does not affirm a gender confused boy as
a girl
they are guilty of conversion therapy so
affirmation
is to tell a boy
that he's a girl
and conversion therapy is to tell a boy
that he's a boy
this is the twisted world that we're now
living in
simply using the word he
is conversion therapy they're already
arresting people for this crime in
canada as you heard in our film what is
a woman
the biden regime wants to see that same
thing happen here
that's how biden can prove his lgbt
bonafides
something that he's desperate to do as
was made clear during his pride speech
yesterday where he uh spent several
minutes
just off the top bragging about all the
gay and trans people in his
administration listen
look last year we hosted this event
and the message is simple
pride is back at the white house
[Applause]
from day one
from day one this has been the most
pro-equality administration in history
led by guys like pete button
and so many others
i think we have more lgbtq plus people
than any administration or every
administration combined
no i really mean it
i i i mean
[Applause]
because i promised when i got elected i
wanted my administration to look like
america
look like america across the board
and we've done that
a record number of out and proud
appointees at every single level of our
government
and as i said you know secretary brutal
who needs no introduction he's doing an
outstanding job of rebuilding america
and i mean that in a literal sense and
not just in terms of what he's doing in
transportation but he's helping rebuild
pride in america
[Applause]
and my public spokesman corrine john
pierre is making
history we're also joined by the
assistant secretary of health and
education and human services admiral
rachel levin
and under secretary of defense sean
steele where's
the secretary of under secretary of
defense there you go thank you very much
for being here
[Applause]
yeah so we want uh the administration to
look like america
and so it has more lgbt people than
every other administration combined
is that how you make it look like
america you want to look like america so
you have rachel levine
is that what america looks like to you
rachel levine
yeah i guess in their mind that's what
that's what america is america's rachel
levine
so you heard that right biden after
throwing shade on obama by calling his
own administration the most pro-equality
in history so not the not the
administration with the first black
president it's no that's not the most of
pro equality he's even more pro-equality
than obama was he also credits pete
buttigieg
with leading his administration and with
rebuilding america and also rebuilding
pride in america
he's done all this as transportation
secretary and in spite of the fact that
he took three months off for maternity
leave uh but he's still been able to do
all that so that's pretty impressive
i think biden is right though i have to
admit i mean who among us has not been
overcome with pride because a gay guy
named pete is our transportation
secretary i hear people saying it all
the time go up to any american on the
street and ask them why they're proud of
america and the first thing they'll say
is pete budage of course
now this obviously is just a bunch of
absurd pandering by somebody who doesn't
really believe any of this stuff to the
extent that he's able to believe
anything at all anymore
but does anyone in the administration
actually believe
any of this i mean do they believe that
it's abusive and oppressive to not drug
and mutilate kids
do they believe that it's conversion
therapy to call a boy he
do they believe that we should be
chopping the breasts off of 15 year old
girls do any of the politicians in
washington actually agree with and
believe in
the extremist lgbt agenda to this extent
maybe a few of them do
but most have been in the public eye for
decades
most prominent ones anyway and yet never
once up until very recently mentioned
their affinity for chemically castrating
14 year olds
they push this now for ideological and
political reasons of course
and that makes it all the more sinister
and all the worse
that they're not really true believers
they don't believe it they know what
they're saying
they're only going to continue to double
down
they're not going to just stop
unless we stop them that is
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know life happens fast and it can
end
even
faster you picture yourself living to a
ripe old age but then you walk outside
and get hit by a bus it happens all the
time could happen to you
if it doesn't you're going to want to
have a plan in place otherwise the state
the people you hate the people who are
trying to indoctrinate your kids take
your guns steal your freedom they're
going to step in and take control of
your assets when you're gone they're
going to determine what legacy you leave
behind you already got hit by a bus this
is just insult to injury don't let the
state decide what happens to your
children should something happen to you
instead take five minutes and set up a
will through epic will starting at just
119 you choose who raises your kids you
choose who gets your useless crap after
you're gone here's what i want you to do
go to epicwell.com and use promo code
walsh you'll get a 10 discount on epic
will's complete will package that yes
could take only five minutes to set up
many of our families daily wire are now
protected thanks to epic will why don't
you do the same go to epicwell.com and
enter promo code walsh and do something
for your family today so this was
interesting there are some protesters
who crashed a drag queen story hour
event in california over the weekend now
we've seen some of the footage of
protests outside of drag queen story
hour events other drag queen events
where kids are brought there uh we know
what happened in texas with the the drag
event at a gay bar and kids were brought
in by their abusive parents there were
protesters outside people confronting
the drag queens outside which is good
but in this case um the protesters went
all the way into the building and
actually into the event itself to
confront the drag queen and the parents
and let's hear how that confrontation
went
so who brought the training
who brought the pedophile
hello
no thank you who brought the pedophile
we want to know you're required we want
to know oh we're medically exempt thank
you though
who brought the pedophile
i just want to know
your children
well then why is the pedophile here
why did you no no
[Music]
why did you bring the pedophile
i
why would you want to bring children to
this why
really good question they asked there
why would you want to
expose your kids to this
good question i'd love to hear an answer
to that they don't have an answer at
least not an answer they're going to say
out loud why would you want to expose
your kids to this
i mean you want your kids to go to the
library hear a story you want a kid
that's totally understandable
i read stories to my kids all the time
uh we brought our kids to story times at
libraries they used to be a pretty
uncontroversial thing
why do you need a cross-dressing man to
read the story is the question
why do you need a man who to is acting
out his sexual fetish
um
why do you need to incorporate that into
the story time
why
good question answer now the drag queen
there who who showed up um
cross-dressing for kids to read this
story you know he of course has been in
front of media talking about how
terrified he is now and how what a
terrible thing this was
um how uncomfortable he is now
but here's the thing uh in in a
civilized society and an insane society
you should be made uncomfortable
when you're going to do this in front of
kids
okay people involved in combining drag
queens and kids if they feel
uncomfortable about that
they feel like what they're doing is a
little bit uh contentious
that that's how they should feel like
you shouldn't feel
like it's a normal comfortable thing
to just combine kids and drag queens
because it's not normal and it's not
okay
and this is at a library by the way
let's let's keep that in mind this is at
a library this is a this is a tax-funded
institution
so other taxpayers have every right
to voice their disapproval
of what their tax money is being used to
do
and even if it isn't a tax-funded
institution this is child abuse
and people have every right to express
their disapproval of child abuse now
um that's what i would say anyway but
law enforcement they're saying something
different in fact they are now
investigating this as a hate crime
what you just saw there is a hate crime
a hate crime against
who drag queens drag queens are now a
protected class of people
i mean what's what's the
you know this isn't even we're going to
try to charge them with disturbing the
peace or
anything like that
harassment i mean they might try to
throw some of those charges on there too
i'm sure they will but uh we're not
talking about that part of it okay
hate
crime now even according to the way the
hate crime laws are written and there
are a lot of problems with the way
they're written there are a lot of
problems with just the hate crime
category in general but
the way it's supposed to work is that if
you
do something discriminatory or uh
in a harassing manner towards a
protected class of people
and again the fact that there are
protected classes
which means that there are then
unprotected classes the fact that we
have this is in itself a huge problem
and also unconstitutional i would say
because everybody's guaranteed equality
under the law and when you single out
certain classes as protected and others
other classes as not then that's not
equality under the law but putting that
aside for a second
are drag queens protected classes now
that's like a demographic
a guy who enjoys cross-dressing because
now that's their that's their own
category of people
says
yahoo news california police are
investigating after a group of men
allegedly interrupted a drag queen story
hour to the library in san francisco bay
area the men who police believe to be
part of the far right proud boys
reportedly yelled homophobic and
anti-lgbtq plus slurs
now that part the homophobic and
anti-lgbt slurs i didn't hear that in
the video now the video does go on for a
while longer maybe their other videos
too i don't know i didn't hear in that
clip
um and they don't in in this article
they don't quote what exactly those
slurs were
everything i heard in that clip was
directed at the the drag queen and the
whole concept of combining drag queens
and kids that's their problem
on saturday afternoon police responded
to calls around 1 30 p.m that there was
a disturbance at the san lorenzo library
during the story reading
authorities said that a group of five
men had disrupted the event which was
attended by children parents and
community members the men began to shout
homophobic and transphobic slurs at the
event organizer the men were described
as extremely aggressive with a
threatening violent demeanor causing
people to fear for their safety
an active hate crime investigation is
underway
as is an investigation into the annoying
and harassing of children
uh the annoying and harassing of
children
annoying is that actual crime now first
of all
being annoying is a crime
there are a lot of people i know who
need to be arrested in that case
but no they weren't harassing the
children if they were asking anybody it
was the adults that's what all this is
directed at
they were there because their belief is
that the children are being harassed by
the event
and they're correct in that belief by
the way the police added as we celebrate
pride month we will be swift in our
response to any incidents where there
are threats to harm members of this
community of what community the drag
queen community
or are you saying that uh dressing in
drag in front of children
is what
synonymous
with the gay community in general
i think there are plenty of gay people
that disagree with that
you know i'm pretty sure there are
plenty of gay people who would say that
uh uh
no
you can you can be a po just because
you're opposed to
um drag queen story hour
like that has nothing to do with me
this to me seems um very it's it's sort
of a similar thing to when uh when
people
just like that what's going on with jack
del rio
who criticized blm rioting and then is
accused of being racist
by people who i guess are
saying are insinuating
that violent rioting is an essential
part of black culture
that's what they're saying in that if
you oppose violent writing then you're
opposing black people
so the law enforcement here i guess
they're saying the same thing kind of
about the gay community they're saying
that uh dressing in dragon from the
children is an essential part of gay
culture and therefore if you oppose that
then you oppose gay people that's what
they are saying
they're either saying that or they're
saying that um
that drag queens themselves are their
own protected class protected community
whatever however you explain it it's
totally
insane
absolute nonsense
um
the host drag queen panda dulce told
local public radio station
kqed that when the men came in shouting
uh
okay they're using the female pronouns
oh my gosh
that when the men came in shouting at
her
she was eventually escorted out of the
room by a security guard for her safety
that's the other thing i've actually
noticed this recently when when the
media talks about drag queens
they use the female pronoun
but the whole point of a drag queen is
that it's a man dressing as a woman
that's what a drag queen is by
definition
so now they are connecting drag queens
and transgenderism
but a drag queen by if if it's a if it's
a woman
dressed like that then it's not drag
that's just a woman
so what i guess in the media in the
article they are just sort of referring
to her
to referring to him as the character
that he's playing which is a female
uh
dolce whose name is kyle casey chu
says i didn't know if they were armed i
was only acutely aware of the fact that
neither myself nor any of the other
librarians were armed
they totally freaked out the kids they
got right in our faces they jeered they
attempted to escalate the violence
i didn't see any of that did you i
didn't see in anyone's face i didn't see
an attempt to escalate the violence
and i didn't see them attacking the kids
in any way whatsoever
all right let's move to this from the
daily caller it says
uh
there's a movement a foot now it says
republicans in the texas state
legislature led by former department of
health and human services chief of staff
brian harrison are requesting that a
deputy whhs secretary provide them with
the department's legal definition of
womanhood president joe biden created a
gender policy council in march 2021 with
the goals of reviewing the trump
administration's approach to the title
ix and addressing uh gender inequity in
the us and globally since then he's
ordered bans on discrimination and
education based on gender identity which
could lead to male students using female
bathrooms is preparing to require states
to permit the prescription of puberty
blockers and other hormones to minor
patients
however the republicans note that by
administration has not publicly stated
how they define the term woman under
federal law
so this
is as always
a good rhetorical tactic
of course what my whole film is built
around of trying to get them to define
the word woman because it brings down
the gender ideology house of cards but
it's more than that also it's actually a
legal question
that if if under title ix women are
supposed to be protected in all these
various ways
then there is a legal question about how
you define the word what actually is a
woman
so we could talk about this in the
rhetorical sense we could talk about it
ideologically you know we can have this
discussion but there's also a legal
question here
which is one of the reasons why marcia
blackburn asking kataji brown jackson
that was not a gotcha moment
i mean it's never a gotcha moment to ask
somebody what is a woman it's only if
it's a gotcha moment that's their own
fault
okay if you can get got by that question
that just shows you there's something
wrong with your own viewpoint and your
own worldview but it's actually it's a
legal question
because there are laws protecting women
and so what do we mean by that who who
qualifies under that under those kind of
laws
uh eventually this this is something
that's going to make its way up to the
supreme court i mean there's going to
have to be a ruling on this
and yet they of course can't define it
so it's a brilliant move by the texas
republicans i think more news out of the
administration the energy secretary has
been asked as you might imagine um if
there's any plan to bring down gas
prices
and all these various secretaries of all
these agencies uh most of the time you
wonder what exactly are they doing with
their time we know what pete budages has
been doing he's been hanging out at his
house
um
but most of the time there's not a lot
for them to do but then you have
situations that arise where okay
this this is your purview like you
should actually be doing something here
so we've got a major problem with gas
prices right now crisis level problem
and it's only getting worse you're the
you're the energy secretary
now it's time to leap into action this
is your turn let's do something about it
and um here's what she has to offer
listen
if you filled up your ev
by charging and you filled up your gas
tank
with gasoline and you have the same size
tank you would save 60 dollars per
philip
by going electric rather than using
gasoline so it's very compelling case
but again to your point we want to bring
down the price at the point of
purchase right so the first answer is
let's go to electric cars that's the
answer to the gas price the real answer
for her is you know gas prices aren't a
problem what's the answer to the gas
prices problem well to the by
administration there is no problem this
is actually a good thing and they've
been pretty clear about that
they see this as an opportunity they
they do not want to fix these problems
that's a big reason why you know we
talked about incompetence in the buy
administration there's a lot of
incompetence of course but is it is it
pure incompetence
that has led to these problems as a pure
incompetence that prevents them from
solving the problems no there's also
just a lack of will lack of desire they
don't see it as a problem
uh the other thing that the
administration's doing and in some of
these interviews the energy secretary
has been calling on the uh the oil
companies
to step up and be patriots and just
bring down the prices on their own
there are a lot of problems with that
proposed solution but one of them is
that you're you're our you are
beseeching right the the oil companies
while in the next breath
announcing your intention to bankrupt
them
so that's just that's
that's not great outreach let's just say
you have difficulty working
with someone or with an industry when
that is your sales pitch
hey help us out right now in the short
term and uh five years from now we'll
bankrupt you sound good
not exactly gonna work all right uh
moving on to this ibram kendy has a new
book out and the new book is called how
to raise an anti-racist
so he's going back to the same well he
already has anti-racist baby he wrote
that one i believe and now he's got how
to raise an anti-racist
um
in all of these books you find them all
over barnes and noble and they they do
all these media interviews and
everything nobody actually reads or buys
these books um but he was on msnbc
talking about the book and he said a few
things that i actually think are worth
responding to let's
listen so uh tell tell everybody why you
wrote the book
well i wrote the book because the the
more that i that i researched
uh
this issue about race and children the
more that i continued on as a father
the more i realized that kids are
actually the most vulnerable
to racism
but but they're the ones who were least
likely to engage about it and so i
wanted to write a book that would allow
parents and teachers and caregivers to
figure out ways to protect our children
from these simplistic messages like dark
is ugly and light
you know is good so they can grow up to
be
whole people who recognize
racial equality and your message is that
parents should understand that children
uh are already forming opinions at a
very early age some research says as
early as three or four years old
they do and that's the unfortunate truth
but according to scholars by three years
old our kids have an adult-like concept
of race by three years old our kids are
attaching
uh qualities like smartness and honesty
and cleanliness
to skin color and all the while parents
are are thinking and teachers that our
kids aren't thinking about skin color or
even seeing it and so we're not stepping
in to counteract those messages and we
need to
okay
he says we've got to counteract the
message that kids are getting the dark
skin is ugly and light skin is good
where are those messages exactly
where are they hearing those messages i
mean who is saying that who exactly is
saying that can you give me one example
give me like one modern example
of
that message being promoted anywhere
least of all to kids where exactly are
they getting it i mean they're certainly
not getting it in in media in hollywood
they're getting like almost the opposite
actually of that message um they're not
getting it in school they're so where
are they getting it what are you talking
about
yeah so i i bravely am speaking out
against the the message that uh dark
skin is
ugly
well it's good it's it's always really
brave to speak out against a a you know
an idea that nobody is proposing in the
first place
but more to the point he says that kids
are the most vulnerable to racism
and that again is the opposite of the
truth
that's just not true at all
um in fact kids
it it doesn't actually occur to kids
to be racist and how do i know that well
i know that because um i've been around
kids i have kids
like i'm familiar with the concept of
childhood i was a kid at some point so
there's a lot of just sort of
um experience including lived experience
that tells us this
um i also know because i grew up
in the 90s
when there was not this obsession over
race it wasn't it wasn't a racial utopia
but it was not the same obsession
and i mentioned before i can remember
going to uh
going to grade school
in a very racially diverse area and all
people lots of uh
of black classmates asian so on and so
forth
and yes as a kid you notice
the physical differences of course
you notice it but you don't attach a lot
of significance to it
you might have some dumb like childlike
sort of innocent questions about
how how exactly does it happen that
people look different or end up with
different color skin and all that kind
of stuff in fact those aren't really
dumb questions at all actually
um so you might have questions like that
and kids might be prone to saying things
that are kind of awkward because they
don't know any better
but they don't attach kids actually do
not attach significance to these things
they just basically see people as people
and
just what take your kid to a playground
anywhere and just see how they're
playing with with the kids they don't
they don't stop like you're not gonna
see kids on a playground
stop another kid and say oh no you have
a different skin color you're not gonna
play with us it just doesn't happen
so
if you were to just leave kids alone
they're already most kids are already
living in a very uh diverse environment
okay so if you were to just
let them be kids
leave them alone
kind of leave them to their own devices
on this particular issue
it's not going to be an issue
no it's people like ibrahim x kendi
who have to come around and tell the
kids that there's a significance here
no what so it's actually the opposite
message
he
and all the so-called anti-racist people
they're the ones telling kids that oh
no you know what you guys all look
different and the fact that you look
different is very significant
and and here are all the reasons why
it's significant
and not only that but the other thing
they say to the kids is well you see
these these kids over here these are the
white kids
and they're their ancestors are all
racist and they're oppressive
and you over here you're the black kids
and so and you've been and you're being
systemically oppressed in fact you're
being oppressed by these kids over here
and and you might not even know it and
they don't know that they're oppressing
you but they are
and here are all the privileges that
these kids these white kids are getting
that you're not getting and it may seem
like you get the same privileges and
you're living basically the same kind of
life but you're not no they get all
these privileges and you don't get them
so people like ibrahim kennedy they're
the ones doing that
under the guise of anti-racism of curing
kids of a racism that they don't even
actually have in the first place they
are creating it they're creating racial
divisions and of course they're doing it
entirely
on purpose
all right um speaking of black issues i
thought this was great from ron desantis
here he is expressing his pride and i
thought this was uh you know ron sanchez
gets a bad rap sometimes as um not being
the most progressive guy but here he is
expressing his pride
in um in one of his most
prominent african-american supporters
let's watch this
so what i would say you know i'm focused
on 2022
but with elon musk what i would say is
you know i welcome support from african
americans what can i say
[Applause]
so somebody asked him about about elon
musk saying that he potentially will
support him in 2024 and that was his
answer so that's
uh you got to appreciate that i mean
he's not the first one to make that joke
but to hear a joke like that which isn't
even really a joke i mean it is actually
true technically that elon musk is he's
an african-american immigrant he is
but hear that joke from a prominent
politician that's just that's uh
yet another
reason to support ron desantis for 2024
if he runs and you know the word on the
street is that he probably will i hope
he does
and look i'm not going to make this i'm
not going to go into a whole nother
thing here about comparing ron desantis
to president trump but i will just say
that desantis
to my mind is a more effective leader a
more effective executive has been way
more effective at giving at getting
conservative legislation actually passed
conservative policies put in place and
i also think he's funnier i think he's i
think he's he's he's much better
actually at trolling the left even than
trump is not that that actually matters
all that much for a president neither
are other things that are priorities
over that but if you care about that um
to whatever extent you care about it i i
think that desantis is actually better
at that um he's just he's a funnier more
clever guy and that that does actually
matter in terms of politics
quick on your feet able to think on your
feet um having some wit you know i i
just think desantis is
clearly
uh
by far in a way should be considered the
favorite over trump here's uh speaking
of which
so reporter kimberly leonard of business
insider tweeted this a couple days ago
she said governor governor desantis
who's 43
still has over 21 000 student loans he
doesn't trade individual stocks his net
worth is 318 thousand dollars far lower
than many top politicians and if he runs
for president he may clock in at the
lowest net worth in a crowded field so
yet another reason to like descendants
he's only 43 i actually thought he's a
little bit older than that he's only 43
years old and he's basically a normal
human being i mean he's
he's uh relatively well off you know
compared to the average salary in the
united states but his net worth is only
you know only in you could say only in
comparison to most other people who run
for president he's not a millionaire
he's not a billionaire
um
again that's that's not the most
important thing i think the most
important thing is is this going to be
an effective leader
who can actually get these put these
policies in place that's what matters
the most
but all the even when you look at all
the peripheral stuff i still think he
stacks up really well
all right
before i get to the comment section
there's one other thing that i think is
important that i have to play for you so
the audubon society is a group dedicated
to conserving
the bird population and um
you may think that there's no way to
politicize or sort of wokify birds
but you would be wrong
so let's put the tweet up first this is
from the audubon society they say this
pride month audubon partnered with
drag queen and intersectional fem wait
sorry drag queen an intersectional
environmentalist patty gonia
patty gonia okay i just got that
uh to bring you birds tell us
before we continue i just need to can we
just stop for a moment on um
drag queen and intersectional
environmentalist
uh birds tell us the song of the
meadowlark a message of hope for the
future of our planet as we face climate
change if we choose to listen okay so
this is a song
by patty gonia the intersectional
environmentalist drag queen
and this is all to uh this is all for
the sake of defending
the birds and conserving the bird
population
uh let's let's listen to the song
together
[Music]
could you stop pause it there for a
second
that guy can we go back to what he looks
like is his uh what this guy is dressed
as because i just i i always ask this
question and yeah
i don't understand what is what are the
drag queens going for like who
who are you supposed to be
why is it that drag queens always look
like the evil stepmothers in disney
films i i just don't understand it
anyway we haven't heard the song yet so
i don't want i don't want to trash the
guy too much until we hear the song
let's keep going
[Music]
birds tell us that the world is changing
that the climate is changing
they sing it over us
and around us
in their songs
and in the songs they no longer sing
[Music]
will we choose to listen
birds tell us
do you know why birds sing just before
dawn no i don't
people believe it's to tell each other
that they made it through the night no
it's not that's not i don't believe that
as a way of saying i'm still here no
it's like it's mating it's nothing to do
with this
as a way of saying i made it that's not
why bird sings that's incorrect bird
information this is the autobahn
society think you at least get some
correct bird facts out of this thing
birds sing to let us all know that
they're still here they survive the
night i don't think so don't turn it
down keep keep playing it right we're
gonna play this entire thing
i've decided
this is character building for all of us
we're gonna make it through this
together is a feathered thing perched
upon the soul
singing
never ceasing
giving
wings this is not supposed to be this is
not supposed to be funny i don't think i
don't think they're going for humor now
this is actually
it can be a quiet sound
what emotional reaction are we supposed
to be having
oh it's over
how am i how are we suppose what
what what are they going for is that i
think that we're supposed to be
like emotionally affected by that
it is true it's it is just they're
beyond parody the left is
quite literally beyond parody at this
point
but i will say one thing watching that i
i am getting some great ideas for my own
interpretive dance so that's the one
positive from this let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
myself martinez says matt wannabe
professor dave had to turn off his
comments on his reply video to you
titled canceled cancel this he was
getting triggered by anyone who
disagreed with him and even f-bombed me
and called me a bigot for using the
harming children excuse quote unquote i
was going out of my way to be respectful
but yeah same attitude as the people you
interviewed in the documentary uh oh
yeah professor dave i forgot that we so
yeah he was the um
he was the smarmy tool bag who
gave his he's you know he was he was too
too cool for school as always and i'll
i'll answer this what is a woman
question i'll give you the facts and
it's just nothing it's just nothing but
nonsense went on for not with nonsense
for 20 minutes
um and never actually answered the
question either
so apparently he has a response to me
titled cancel this and he's turned and
he's turned the comments off that's
great i didn't realize that he i'll have
to go and check that out
um
all right
mountain end says in the early 70s if
you wanted to transition you had to go
through a year of psychoanalyst and
psychotherapy and if they still couldn't
talk you out of it then the doctors
would cut you but until then the
teenager or adult couldn't get the
surgery and doctors agreed to that
regime of waiting a year of therapy what
happened to that system
yeah well that goes back to what we
talked about the beginning of the show
just constantly doubling down constant
progression in the way that cancer
progresses right it's like a progressing
tumor
um
and it just gets worse and worse
because even a system of you have to
wait a year
uh
you know you have to be
even if it was you have to wait a year
you can't be under the age of 18 all
these things
um
even that wouldn't make it okay
because as i've said many times now i i
don't think the doctor should be allowed
to do this kind of thing to anybody
um
but
even that
wouldn't be okay
and yet that would still be somehow an
improvement over the insanity right now
the fact that they don't even have that
like they don't have mandatory
they want mandatory weight waiting times
to buy guns right
is there a mandatory weight for chemical
castration no
um spirit matter says imagine matt has
become an animal rights activist yeah
you know what i'm
this this is what's happening now
because the world's turned on its head
so i'm uh
i had to speak out for animal rights
yesterday
at least the right the right of a horse
to not be crushed like a pancake
from you know morbidly obese people
riding on them so i got to speak out for
animal rights
i have to speak out for the birds now
even
this is this is this is who's looking
out for the birds or these you know you
got a drag queen dancing around
reciting slam poetry so now i got to
take over that i think defending the
birds
and with what is a woman i'm now also
the leading feminist in the world so
along with being the leading lgbt author
so everything is uh everything's just
turned upside down
uh let's see what else we got
jammy git says christina aguilera's
aguilera song is only bettered by rachel
bloom's sex junk on bill nye's
godforsaken show the social engineers
are very clever though every time she
mentions sex i can't help thinking of
sex yes that's that is clever i you know
i read this comment
and you put in my mind that song i
completely forgot about it i blocked it
out of my mind i blocked out of my mind
the existence of bill nye the existence
of that show i think it was on netflix
right
for uh for a very brief and strange
period of time bill nye had a show on
netflix
and then i remembered yes i'd completely
forgotten
this song performed by whoever rachel
bloom is called sex junk and you know
what because you put that in my mind i
almost decided to play it on the show
but like i can't do that even i even
that's too fine i especially can't do
that after the drag queen thing so i can
only choose one one of those things per
show
this week was the premiere of our summer
blockbuster tara on the prairie the wait
has been long but it's finally over gina
is back it was 18 months ago when disney
fired gina carano over a couple of
social media posts daily wire hired her
on the spot and announced that she'd be
starring in and producing our next
original film well that film is here and
you can watch it right now tara the
prairie is a raw and visceral western
with gina as you've never seen her
before like a woman who refuses to be
canceled she fights tooth and nail to
defend her family from a gang of
bloodthirsty outlaws hell-bent on
revenge the daily wire's mission is to
bring you films that challenge the
viewer without any agenda except to make
great movies i'm really excited for
everyone to see this film it's a high
action western without the wokeness so
go to dailywire.com gina to become a
member and watch the film today that's
dailywire.comgina
now speaking of westerns ben shapiro's
third thursday book club is back tonight
at 8 p.m eastern and this month ben will
be unpacking shane
by jack shaffer considered to be the
great american western novel i think
also the great american western film as
well
and my personal favorite he'll share his
notes and analysis with you as well as
answer all of your questions live
this isn't your average book club it's
your chance to engage with ben share
knowledge and deepen your understanding
of the most culturally significant books
ever written to join ben's book club you
need to be an all access member so head
to dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member or upgrade and tune in tonight at
8pm eastern now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel with a vengeance george
washington university which has decided
to discontinue the use of its colonials
moniker and mascot citing concerns about
inclusivity the daily caller reports
quote george washington university's
board of trustees voted to rename the
colonials moniker for the school
in the name of inclusivity according to
a statement from the university the
board voted to change the name in hopes
of finding a name that unifies the
community according to a university
press release the statement reads quote
the committee said that changing names
should be rare but also recognize that
the gw community was divided on whether
to change the colonials moniker in this
case the special committee found that
the colonials moniker does not
adequately match the values of gw and
could no longer serve its purpose as a
name that unifies the community
now what exactly is the problem with
colonial
well a student petition which garnered
only 550 signatures in a school with a
total enrollment of 27 000
yet they got their way anyway
this is what the petition says quote
we as students of the georgia washington
university believe it is of great
exigence that the university changed its
official mascot the use of colonials no
matter how innocent the intention is
received as extremely offensive by not
only students of the university but the
nation and the world at large
destination in the world the world is
offended by the george washington
university mascot this is something that
people all across the world are worried
about
go to go down to the uh most
impoverished parts of india and you're
gonna find people who are working just
who are
rocking themselves to sleep worried
about the george washington university
mascot anyway it says the historically
negatively charged figure of colonials
has too deep a connection to
colonization and glorifies the act of
systemic oppression
okay yes it's uh it's received this way
they say the people who are complaining
actually recognize that their
interpretation is not necessarily
accurate the colonial mascot was not
meant in the way they're taking it
obviously yet they've chosen to receive
it that way and so the mascot must be
changed they've invented an offensive
mascot in their heads a mascot with that
that glorifies systemic oppression and
they're projecting that figment of their
imagination onto the real world
what's more they know that they're doing
this and they acknowledge it
but perhaps we shouldn't judge them too
harshly until we know what nicknames
they suggest to take its place i mean if
they have an idea that's significantly
better than the old mascot maybe that's
reason enough to
make the change fortunately they do list
their suggestions in the petition so
this is what they say
alternative nickname recommendations are
revolutionaries
river horses or
hippos
now revolutionaries that's
not all that bad except that you know
that when they say revolutionaries they
have in mind revolutionary in the sense
of blm rioters and antifa terrorists um
river horse sounds like a gender-neutral
name that some blue-haired yoga
instructor would give her child a child
she probably had via surrogacy
but then
hippos
i mean maybe there's some connection
between hippos and george washington
that i'm not aware of but even so
you could not choose a goofier name or
animal for your mascot now it is true
that hippos are actually the deadliest
animals in africa
but intestinal parasites are deadly also
and i assume you wouldn't want to make
that into your mascot
or maybe you would
the george washington university
intestinal parasites that's a nice ring
to it and it's appropriate too because
there is a kind of parasitic infestation
happening in our university system right
now which leads to ridiculous decisions
like this
specifically
there are three reasons why
changing the colonial mascot is very
stupid so let's go through them briefly
number one
the colonial nickname allegedly promotes
and celebrates colonialism therefore
making it offensive
but i thought mascots
denigrate and dishonor the thing or
person who's been made into the mascot
isn't that why we're changing all the
native american mascots because in that
case we're told that it's racist to
reference indians or indian culture
with a mascot because it degrades them
so wouldn't that mean by the same logic
that the colonial mascot actually
insults and degrades colonialism
therefore making it a super woke and pc
choice for a name
so which is it do we celebrate a group
of people by turning them into mascots
or do we insult them
now i would answer the former mascots
certainly are meant to celebrate to pay
homage to whatever has been chosen as
the mascot the left seems to agree with
that interpretation when it comes to
names like colonials but then they take
the exact opposite interpretation when
it comes to a name like cleveland
indians for example which is why that
team was was uh was renamed last year
and in that case the name indians had
been chosen as an homage to a native
american man who played for cleveland in
the late 19th century
back when they were called the cleveland
spiders for some reason but people
started calling them the cleveland
indians because of this player and then
eventually they adopted that as a name
which is a great honor to
that player i mean they named the team
after a native american player
and after over a century with that name
they changed it so as to no longer
insult native americans by paying
tribute to them with a mascot
and that is that's because the mascot
did not pay tribute we were told it was
an insult
yet colonials
does pay tribute to colonialism so none
of this makes any sense
number two here's a really important
detail
the the colonials referenced by the
colonial moniker
did not engage in colonialism they were
colonists who actually abolished
colonialism in what is now the united
states
by forming the united states quite
famously they fought a war to end
colonialism here and to establish a
sovereign nation
the left's interpretation of colonial
might make sense if the university's
mascot was king george but it's not it's
george washington
hence the name george washington
university
and george washington led an army to
free the colonies from imperial rule and
thus again end colonialism
so we see that the argument for getting
rid of the mascot makes no sense on two
different levels and we're not even done
yet number three
um there is nothing inherently evil
least of all racist about colonialism
and colonization itself even if it
happened to be true that colonial was
meant to be a sort of vague homage to
colonialism in general it's not true at
all and only an idiot could think it was
true but put that aside
if it was true i still wouldn't agree
with changing the name because i don't
agree with the premise that colonialism
is some sort of inherent evil
not every form of it has been good and
certainly abuses have occurred within
the context of colonization that's why
the revolutionary war was fought after
all but historically colonization was
simply one country or kingdom
sending explorers and pioneers to
establish settlements in other parts of
the world yes they were looking to
expand their reach and their power but
that's how the world was settled all
people everywhere across the entire
world looked to expand and stretch you
know beyond their own horizons
this often led to conflict and violence
but that's how civilization came to be
it was driven by the fundamental desire
to expand into the unknown to reach
beyond apparent limitations
colonization is a different sort of
thing though in the modern age when the
world is is known
and already settled more or less
but it was different historically
the world was not always this way
which may come as a surprise to the
students at george washington university
history after all does not seem to be
their forte
and that's why in the end they are
canceled at least the 550 who signed
that petition are cancelled and we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
well if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe and if you want to
help spread the word please give us a
five star review also tell your friends
to subscribe as well we're available on
apple podcast spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts we're there also be
sure to check out the other daily wire
podcasts including the ben shapiro show
michael knowles show the andrew clavin
show thanks for listening the matt walsh
show is produced by sean hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
production manager pavo valdoski our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
the economy collapses the quadruple
vaxxed dr fauci catches kovid and
abortion supporters attack 23 pro life
centers check it out on the michael
knowles show